these hearings of the subcommittee are
narcotics terrorism and international
operations of the Foreign Relations
Committee will come to order
I was informed that senator D'Amato is
on his way from the airport he was
coming down and is slightly delayed I
was trying to allow him time to be able
to be here for the beginning let me just
make a couple of brief comments by way
of introduction to this week and where
we are going and where we have been six
weeks ago this subcommittee held the
first set of hearings on international
drug trafficking and at the beginning of
those hearings I indicated the literally
frightening degree to which I believed
that narco trafficking and the narco
dollar has permeated the everyday
affairs of countries that we deal with
I also stressed at that time that in my
opinion this was a threat that was
defining itself as really more serious
than many of those with which we have
been preoccupied in the daily dialogue
of this country these past few years in
some ways some people may feel that
we've learned and heard too much about
drugs lately but drugs are literally
tearing at the fabric of American life
they are killing adult and child they're
undermining our institutions they're
filling our jails they're depleting our
national energy and our creativity and
they are costing us billions of dollars
in various social costs in recent weeks
we've come to understand even more as
we've watched events unfold in Panama
about the scope of the criminal
enterprise we've seen how it threatens
whole countries and how it upsets the
stability of an already very fragile
hemisphere these hearings continue today
in an effort to further shed light on
this scourge to better understand its
scope and its nature so that we can
better determine what we're going to do
about it if in fact we're really going
to respond to it so we begin today an
examination that picks up where we left
off we will look at additional countries
we will also revisit Panama briefly with
Jose bland own in order to literally
pick up where we left off and to review
where the situation is today as well as
to touch on some matters which we were
not able because of time constraints to
go into during the last session it seems
to me that through all of the exercise
of last week and of the events of the
last few weeks it's clear that one thing
leaps out at all of us and it's a tragic
recognition and that is that despite all
the rhetoric despite a good beginning at
education in this country despite a
congressional law passed last year
despite all of the talk about a war on
drugs there has not been a real war and
more pointedly the drugs have not been
the priority that public officials have
said they were that will become even
more clear as we examine not only what
has happened in other countries but as
we examine how we ourselves have made
decisions that have put us where we are
and I think that will be one of the most
interesting parts of these hearings we
have a great many witnesses that we will
hear from we will hear from Jose blendin
we will hear from former ambassador to
Costa Rica Frances McNeil we will hear
from a number of people who have been
incarcerated or some who are not
incarcerated who have themselves been
involved in both the narcotics
trafficking as well as some of the other
efforts which have resulted in the
problems that I've talked
about Senator Bob Graham of Florida has
a specific interest in Haiti and has
asked that I postpone certain portions
of Haiti until he returns from a trip to
Moscow I have agreed to do that and we
will touch on Haiti in the course of
this week but we will complete Haiti
upon his return in addition senator
Mitch McConnell who is the ranking
member of this committee has business in
his state and is unable to be here for a
good portion of it therefore we have
agreed to postpone the part of the
reappearance of Ramon million Rodriguez
and others until Monday of next week but
mr. Rodriguez will nevertheless appear
this week as to certain matters that are
of importance to the general inquiry
finally Jose bland Doan is back with us
and I am delighted to welcome you back
Mr bland own we are going to for those
who were not here previously let me
explain that we have simultaneous
translation that has been provided us by
the State Department and we will proceed
so that for those of you who were in the
audience who wished to share the
translation as we go along there are
headsets available to everybody and one
channel will be English to Spanish the
other is Spanish to English simultaneous
and we will proceed through that means
although mr. Blandon you and I have
conversed many occasion in English if
you feel you would like to do so at this
time we obviously invite you to do so at
any time I would ask you if you would
stand please so that I could Reece where
you would you raise your right hand
please and do you promise to tell the
truth the whole truth and nothing but
the truth so help you God thank you mr.
Bandhu
would you please state your full name
again identify yourself for the record
me nobody will say it but on my name is
Jose blonde Don Castillo the Chairman is
trying to get the correct channel here
which one am i all right miss blendin
blandin you are the same Jose bland on
who testified here before this committee
about six weeks ago in glory yes
now mr. Blandon at that time you told us
considerable amount about the specifics
of general Noriega x' involvement in
narcotics trafficking we did not however
discuss a great deal about the money
laundering process itself nor did we
discuss some of the involvements with
other countries although we did touch on
aspects of general Noriega x'
involvement in gun-running and his links
to cuba today we would like to explore a
number of new areas areas which you
personally did not go into but
specifically I want to pursue them
because they are important in terms of
corroborating the testimony of other
witnesses let me just interrupt my own
questions here to welcome senator
d'amato senator d'amato as I explained
to you Senator McConnell as the ranking
member was not here senator D'Amato is
the ranking member of the Senate drug
caucus he is at a long participation in
the investigation with respect to Panama
and a long interest in this area and I'm
delighted that his help he has been
extremely helpful both his staff and he
himself to our investigative efforts and
I'm delighted to welcome in here again
for this week started about oh do you
want to open let me just move over
but the chairman um let me say that when
two months ago you fell at first held
these hearings there was a great deal of
skepticism I heard many people who
approached me and even some of our
colleagues with respect to what the
useful purpose would be served it's my
belief mr. chairman that you have
demonstrated quite clearly and
convincingly the immense power and the
corrupting influence of the
international drug cartel and indeed
that we owe this committee and yourself
personally that a gratitude for
persisting in not just one or two days
of headline-grabbing but the day-in and
day-out work that you and your staff
have continued behind the scenes in
deposing the various witnesses in laying
the format so that one can so clearly
demonstrate what is taking place in and
maybe a the dawn of awakening as
striking our our communities and some of
our leaders I would hope as we continue
to hear of the incredible violence that
breaks out in community after community
throughout throughout our land and mr.
chairman let me suggest that it is
directly tied to this international drug
cartel and we also suggest to the
doubting Thomases who initially and by
the way let's put on the record those in
the defense community and establishment
those in the intelligence community and
establishment the Oldboy Network who are
so quick to denigrate anyone who could
possibly in any way cast aspersions upon
maybe why they have
not risen to the scene why they had not
identified the drug ring as a very
serious one why they were dealing for
example for so many years with Noriega
and others that that your testimony and
facts have have demonstrated and so well
mr. Blandon whose credibility has been
established without doubt was first
characterized as some kind of power
seeking person who had political
aspirations we had other witnesses whose
motivations were questioned and now that
in some cases hos they blend those
prophecies as to how Noriega not only
operated but would operate in the future
and has been borne out why those critics
have seemed to somewhat quiet down in a
melt away
I would suggest though that instead of
them attempting to protect turf and what
their past actions wear or should have
been that they would become more
concerned in the business of the people
how we remedy the situations that exist
mr. Chairman I have a lengthier
statement but I know we have a lot of
business at hand I'd ask that I be
permitted to submit the the statements
of reddit's and in its entirety and I
look forward to working with you in the
in the days and weeks and months ahead
well thank you very much senator D'Amato
without objection your full testimony
will be made part of the record and I
appreciate your comments very very much
I might add that staff here led by Jack
Blum and Kathleen Smith have done just a
superb job totally overworked without
resources and it's really remarkable
what they've been able to to put
together and I think this week will help
to corroborate that there will be some
fascinating testimony and some chilling
testimony some of which will cause us I
think to seriously reevaluate our effort
and to come to a new understanding about
where and how we have to make changes in
order to deal with this problem let me
also remind people while this is not a
court of law
we are not subject to rules of evidence
specifically with respect to hearsay and
ever I have I have endeavored in the
first week of hearings to try to be a
stricter than one might be usually we
are not trying to paint a story that is
not without at least significant
circumstantial linkages where there is
not direct evidence and I think where
there may be some doubts in one person's
testimony by the end of the week where
there have been several of those doubts
will be minimized mr. Blandon I want to
remind you as I will remind witnesses
through the week we're not looking for
pre-arranged or any kind of specific
answers we want the truth we want to
know what's happening we don't want
things embellished we don't want things
shaded for any political side whatsoever
these hearings have been dedicated to
letting the chips fall where they may
and that is precisely what we're going
to do is let the chips fall where they
make what we want our facts and what you
have heard know and and while I will
accept obviously testimony that you have
heard other people talking about and so
forth because that's the nature of a
hearing now mr. Blandon first before we
move to discussion of the Medellin
Cartel influence before we discuss the
money laundering which we want to go
into with you more before we discuss
some aspects of the relationship with
Fidel Castro and finally some of the
aspects of Japan and its links to
general Noriega I would like to ask you
quickly because you are here and this is
a critical moment on your perceptions of
where we are with respect to the process
of panama today and the removal of
general Noriega you and i have met along
with senator d'amato and others over the
course of these past weeks you've been
meeting with the administration the
opposition has been working diligently
but I'm concerned secretary Schultz is
in the Middle East defense secretary
Carter Lucia's in
go the president is on the west coast
there seems to be a dispersal of energy
and of leadership and these are critical
moments we are either on the line with
respect to Panama or we are not on the
front pages of the New York Times today
as well as in recent days we've been
reading what senator D'Amato and I
asserted last week at a press conference
which is that there is a major division
within this administration with respect
to policy and at the outset of our
approach on general Noriega we asserted
very clearly that the past relationship
of the CIA the DIA the SOUTHCOM the
military network to general Noriega is
part of what has emboldened him part of
what has allowed him to be able to
believe that he can get away with what
he's been doing to do and I fear that
the ambivalence we read on the front
pages of our newspapers of
administration policy merely reinforces
in him the very perceptions which have
led him to hold on in the first place
and so I'm disturbed about policy
senator D'Amato is disturbed about
policy this may be one of the most
critical moments that we've had to seize
that is being lost it took the
protection of some potentially
graduating doctors in the Grenada that
to call for action it took a lot less
than that with respect to seven and a
half years of effort against Nicaragua
and I think the question has to be asked
why it is when a drug baron of the
importance of general Noriega who has
robbed a people of their democracy is
just sitting there snubbing his nose at
the people of this country as well as at
a country which is indicted in for drug
running what is our policy and I think
that's a legitimate question so in light
of that opening statement and those
fears that I express about where we are
I'd like to ask you your perceptions of
where we are in Panama and what is
happening
thank you very much mr. chairman senator
d'amato
done this in the first place I would
like to email a state that since the
last time that I was here yes yes and so
study they were hearings no solamente me
by not only you know my country but also
in other countries important events have
taken place like an IV that the limb
that have confirmed the seriousness of
the drug general and the general
strategy that the Medellin Cartel and
associates have unleashed in Central
America and the Caribbean and the rest
of Latin America in particular in
particular it was in the Panama the
Panamanian situation at present
Alejo is a reflection of what is our the
extent to which the lover although the
forces around the drugs the militaries
and the extent to instill a group of
military corrupted military civilian
officials and extend the fest of their
power against a people who Laguna de
Panama in the republic of panama
mr. chairman and well in general the
people in general in Apulia repudiated
general in Vienna the Noriega calathea
theology of the church wonderful
presence in Panama I stated its
objection to for him presence in Panama
business sectors have stated their
objection to notice Panama the working
and in sectors have expressed themselves
neither on Alianza política the great
political alliances orange dilutes
opposition parties parties to struggle
against general not gay no Rico so yeah
yeah
he came manthena an organ that only
thing that guy it's when a contains no
dragon power what is the harm others but
even within those rana forces 11:3 some
weeks there was a military uprising whom
cloudy that that clearly - laughs what
is that even within the defense forces
there are serious problems for Noriega
the situation of the Republic's Panama
mr. chairman is extremely seriously the
economic Olbermann economic measures
have obviously in
and have for the first time in danger
either no Diego government I think that
it has been effective our country has
paid a high price so you don't think
we'll do that but I have no doubt I
think you do find that it is willing to
continue to pay this price the embargo I
you need to fundamental nonetheless
there's a fundamental fact that is of
concern to Romania because our have paid
a great price in terms of sacrifice all
of us have risked our well-being our
families our children
una lucha pone a democracy aid for a
struggle for democracy and peace in
panama why you bacon Prabhupada and the
less our country is concerned with all
new about the fact that the United
States government has not yet defined a
clear precise policy with respect to how
to confront them which is not the needle
problem of Noriega versus the United
States but Noriega versus the people in
Panama and the cartel not may begin
against United States society but on
also to him ptosis and he doesn't wanna
mean for us then the Panamanian human
situation in L'Aquila is a situation
that is human which the lack of endanger
decision-making in some we are certain
parts of the US government Huma
peligrosa may make difficult more
dangerous the national interests of our
country and the national interest of the
United States
karaoke in a full Pima semana
nonetheless I think that in recent weeks
as a result of these hearings in this
discussion
Alima we have increased awareness in the
United States and in its put innovators
of a problem I think in the recent past
new italic will see in the United States
has not know where of the extent of the
danger and sentiment by the strata
change in foundation by the Medellin
Cartel in the early 1980s
Leo caboodle I think that their opinion
has been the real lack of knowledge of
the real danger that they represent to
the United States
Yamini Theo and this is apparent today
in my country
David in theater is also apparent
Legrand and Rocco illega song in broad
strokes Noriega in the link between
Panama Noriega Cuba the Santini's
Haiti as una semana a week ago Venezuela
the Venezuelan Minister of Justice was
voted on by Blue Grotto tester hoon had
to step down because of two intervention
drugs in Contra Manu hobros yer Antonia
pasado we find an in blast here the
increase in drug production was 10% then
we know Hannah Dallas in general does it
all up ice in the America most all of
the countries of Latin America are at
one way or another involved in an
illusion Panama saw that struggling I
mean it's not a struggle of only the
Panamanian people we it pull up on a
menial for me the Panamanian people have
made a decision I think it will continue
for struggling that they will be
difficult days it is strange we find it
strange that there's still not a defined
policy with respect to Panama mr.
chairman
when you say mr. Blandon that there
isn't a defined policy today in the
newspaper president of ia was quoted as
saying that he thought the current
sanctions were enough and that they
would do the job do I understand that
you disagree with that problem of
president del Valle with the statement
which based on the fact that I am
selling cause of his present situation
in Louisville because he's isolated from
the discussions and the happenings which
are taking place that is why we last
week when you say isolated you're
referring to the fact that he is in
hiding and that peril is that correct
isolation in the sense that he is no
contact with the rest of the country
have a look through the various
political parties through the various
organizations have supported the
president in other words he is hidden is
in hiding and Sunday's will look look
look therefore we discuss model the
United States the manner of how to solve
this problem and for a week we have been
awaiting a reply and this reply has not
yet been received
let me turn unless senator d'amato has
any policy questions I want to turn to
the Medellin Cartel if I can you you
talked last time we were here
you alluded you do have question I don't
want to change the subject if you wanted
to pursue and I can take questions well
mr. chairman I think it's important if
we get some kind of an understanding as
to as to how the Panamanian Defense
Forces and the people of Panama view
what is taking place as a result
to what might appear to be indecisive
action on the part of of the United
States I'd like to preface that
statement in question because I'd like
to get mr. Blandings opinion if he
believes that the Panamanian people are
beginning to doubt the credibility of
the United States in its actions in
dealing with Noriega or our resolve
number one that's a question I'd like to
ask and number two I'd like to ask mr.
Blandon if he feels that we have been
sending mixed signals to the Panamanian
people and to those who look to the
United States for help in in getting rid
of Noriega
certainly your last question there is no
doubt that the recent developments this
past week have sent signals to regarding
the position of the United States
rebellion and along with the Weiss the
feeling in my country regarding the
United States isn't the impotency is a
feeling signing them up which is based
on many years of cooperation but our
people also views with concern needle 30
views with concern that the United
States London undal is abandoning and
which is not only daughters of drugs
which come to the United States using
the facilities which Noriega has created
and basically affect the youth of the
United States people who is also a fight
for the youth of the United States of
course it is true that in our country
there is a concern and this feeling
though being turned against the United
have mr. senator here before me
a note gentleman will antonio monatti
ever sent to the Embassy of Panama in
Washington in lucky Noriega in which
nori ever una serie they plant the onion
to makes a series of proposals which I
am going to read three or four so that
you could have an idea of how naughty
ever Santana tries a little trick in the
United States these things let me just
ask you would you identify what it is
you're reading from see it's in the
woman this is a document from the
defense forces of Panama headquarters
middle February of this year where did
the document come from documentary in
anticipation comes from the defense
forces of Panama and behind was sent to
the embassy of Panama in Washington so
it was received by ambassador Sosa prior
to the removal of device that accurate
thank you before yellow when the
yesterday was sent I mean after they in
the use of general Noriega regarding the
laws of the United States nor the other
states you're single I do have evidence
politicians of the United States of
America company lumple and all have been
supporting lawyers politicians Panama
involved in drug trafficking and I shall
demonstrate this when it is appropriate
you'll see penguin or Diego I do have
political manipulation of the government
of the United States regarding drugs
follow their little regarding the enough
equally adamant laundering of money for
the American arms traffic which go to
the Latin American countries
you'll see Pingo I do have proof yeah
not here that said meanwhile the
government of the United States should
be concerned by the human rights in
Central America the law does not protect
it the brothers in Guatemala from the
invasion of drug traffickers in that
country in which Ola
there had never been marijuana and
cocaine processing and poppy plantation
also political that the lying policy
against drug of the United States has
not protected our Honduran brothers from
the invasion of cocaine which is brought
from Honduras to the United States the
envelope what Apple in leaving ports
which are just a few kilometers from the
US military bases which are located in
on Duras esplen don't let me just ask
you to go a little bit slower so we can
all follow you more easily thank you
you'll see think we'll Aprilia hi you
have not even says I have proven policy
of the government the United States
shows itself to the world as a protector
drug leaving abandoned it's Latin
American allies llamo pasta and us we
see how Costa Rica don't convert it to
drug trafficking I should like to submit
this for the record I've read some of
the what calls jumps out is that Journal
or yoga says that he has proof proof 70
involved governmental authorities in the
United Malays of drugs in Guatemala in
honor arena and in Costa Rica Mentos now
that document you makes no mention in
Amalapuram into an or not the
involvement of Noriega with Cuba no
other means your thumb for court nor
does it make in 2012 with the Medellin
Cartel poor me conocimiento al Noriega
my knowledge of this problem I have no
doubt that has some proofs of that he is
well aware of this problem of the drug
let me interrupt you for one second if I
can
ambassador Sosa is in the audience here
somewhere
am i correct ambassador Sosa this well I
will ascertain that later from you if I
can as to this document but I will place
this in the record is exhibit did you
have the consecutive number this will be
exhibit number one in the second series
of hearings and it'll be so marked and
we will proceed to verify the
authenticity of this at a later date let
me ask you a question though I meet them
internationally excuse me sir until
opinion submitting this document you
know this is what I am wish to say that
concern which we Panamanians have a que
se trata a
is that this antihero trying to trick or
to confuse us public opinion maha
delante no the incident later on in this
hearing I show evidence is how Fidel
Castro also is trying to confuse us
opinion but are you choking it there is
a fact passed discussions which really
jumped out into us and that is the lack
of knowledge
the deep lack of knowledge in me not
even with those military service from
the United States and of the
intelligence regarding the realities of
the Panamanian Defense Force I won't bet
all over you they have operated on the
basis what do you mean by realities
cuando Manila I refer to reality I refer
to the fact that the relationship they
have the high ends of the results need
opening with the defense forces haven't
been exclusively with Noriega and with
certain other officials nope yeah in the
relationship and what is the impact of
that alien battle is like the impact of
this is schedule gussied up there has
nucleated almost as a truth then they
change level of uncertainty and that
there are no officials in the defense
forces in China to substitute them which
is completely false mr. chairman know
what you let me just fall it so what you
are saying is that it is your perception
there is a reluctance on the part of the
American military to sever the tie with
Noriega because they don't know what
comes after is that the essence of what
you've just said this one up out of the
loop that's a part of the problem a very
serious part well I want to understand
Eric I want to understand precisely what
you've just said then could you reframe
what your your comment to us
those improvements they reports la
comunidad intelligence which the
intelligence community of the United
States has hundred a few mil of what
regarding anomaly Defense Forces of
Panama woman our reports which are very
superficial ones in France what is very
concentrate your attention on Noriega as
the commander and a limited group of
officials of officers this fact make any
agency will be concerned regarding the
future of the Defense Forces because
they do not know what will be the
leadership which will succeed general
Noriega the danger of this mr. chairman
it Gale appears that in practice mas de
la gente por ciento more than 80% of our
military personnel mean anyone
individually is better than or ierra
n-terminal professionally in
professional term in Telugu mano in
human turn this lag gravel this fact is
her mother has ignored the fact that the
Armed Forces of Panama Quentin como si
si lsqin tapasya have been relieved are
an Omega officials who are capable of
taking nuria's place and guaranteeing
the democratic process because they're
not involved with drugs further they
have been professionally trained for
such service unity in the conversations
which we had last week if you didn't it
is clear this a lack of understanding
maybe FIU which i think is a very
serious fault
Angela doesn't have the agencies of the
United States let me ask you one other
tough question if I can you had great
access to general Noriega correct you
read almost all the intelligence
documents during the 80s correcto
and you have testified significantly
here as to general Noriega involvement
in money laundering and drugs and so
forth is there any truth to any of the
allegations made by general Noriega as
to information he has about us
complicity in or involvement in or
knowledge of is there anything that he
has that could embarrass any of those
people he cited in that document
yes indeed you know I've never asked you
that question before have I no never
chairman yes I'm pursuing both lines the
lines of questioning that you have
brought up I'd like to put in the form
of a question in the statement mr.
Blandon is it your opinion that some
panamanians have a feeling that the
United States and particularly the
Defense Department and the intelligence
agency have not recommended more
forceful action in dealing with Noriega
because they are concerned that he has
information that would prove
embarrassing to them and to the United
States
but why propylene in general Noriega
himself thank God I got the new this has
stated that you will recall mr. senator
and well in the ago that the lawyers of
Noriega Miami when they arrived in Miami
from Panama said that Noriega had will
weigh less shown to them which could
endanger that lie helix turn affect the
elections of the United States missile
not mean to personally get opening in
Qatar I believe that in the case of the
Defense Department the basic concern if
you are lie what will be the succession
or kill I formally apologize the
intelligence information regarding the
Defense Forces is very as I said very
limited in addition nor the other but if
I don't you morally prepared reports
llegar a la mythology sent to the United
States under official economy against
Panamanian official perceived as might
be possible successors of here linking
them to leftist policies into Londo law
up linking them into extreme position
Castle this is the case of officers who
today then went on a la cárcel is are in
jail go to the coup d'etat the drug
trafficking group which is in power so
here there has been a process in this
case and this seems to be also because
the discussions we had last week this is
the principal problem that is why we
point this out as a very serious Aaron
as is also a little the error AP model
of under estimating in a portal they
condemn any effort of the cartel to
subvert order in our control FEMA and to
overestimate Knox young geological
community ideological action of
communism I saw the way look what has
happened in practice as chairman I think
it's worthy of note that at this point
take this opportunity to again reinforce
I think what mr. Blandon has indicated
as what has been over a period of time
the cry of the Defense Department and
others and people from the National
Security Council - this senator
personally who's going to take nori
Akers place now that has been stated -
this senator directly from vet rather
high officials in these agencies on more
than one occasion and I think it's the
attitude that permeated and I would hope
that it has changed recently I hope that
it has changed but I wonder if it really
has and I point out something that
should not be lost in the translation of
what mr. blanton has indicated because
for far too long and only have we heard
that cry but we've also had anyone who
comes forward or the possible majors and
Colonels within the defense
establishment and outside painted as
leftist painted as communists painted as
very real and more substantial threats
to the United States and its interest
than Noriega and nothing could be
further from the truth in most cases
they are those people who have
leadership capabilities and qualities at
Noriega has seen to denigrate and we
have right within the Defense Department
or people on contract to the Defense
Department who seem even at this time
bent on carrying that kind of message in
those distortions and so it must send a
terrible signal to the opposition in
Panama when this is coming through
continually well I think it's rather
important that we not lose sight of the
fact that so many who are capable of
leadership and taking it up have been
actually painted as as people who would
pose a greater threat by someone who
himself today has actively been
promoting the interest of the Cubans the
Soviets the leftist within and maybe it
has taken these final acts within the
last several weeks of a man of
desperation to wake us up to the
distortions that one Nestor Sanchez
seems to have created over a period of
time mr. Sanchez being an individual who
up to rather recently worked directly
for the Defense Department and may or
may not be on contract at the present
time and who seems to to still be in a
position to leak out information when
the Defense Department meets with a
group of majors who come from Panama who
attempt to give to the Defense
Department information as to how they
could use it I'd like to just just be
supportive of what I think mr. Blandon
has made in a way of a very
comprehensive analysis and I'd leave
with one further thought mr. chairman as
it relates to this plan Don do you
believe that the Defense Department but
they're the people here our Defense
Department are speaking to sufficient a
sufficient breath enough Panamanian
people to get the correct analysis are
they still continuing to to be web to
the to their old their old system have
they have they do they speak to
sufficient Panamanian people in your
view to get a more accurate picture of
what the situation is and who could who
could fill the power vacuum within the
Panama Defense Forces
it will aim for monsoon ahead as a
monopolist from the information of last
week mr. senator couple of minutes I
think that for the first time officers
of the Department of Defense of the
United States who you don't in Italy or
had had the opportunity to discuss with
another group of officers Panamanian
officers regarding other realities other
facts little new oil but once again in a
gimmick except like Chaplin gave up on a
man the scheme which is been raised in
Panama is a very rigid one to Richard
eldest you look a little echo no city
you're not wishing to recognize the
error then they insist on the error
continuing it means you know and now
that you have mentioned a nipple sunset
Yuki CF Nestor Sanchez as you'd like to
state something which concerns us in a
new panel last year you know can I can i
before you do I want to come back to
Nestor Sanchez but I want to identify
him a little more for the purposes of
the this particular hearing and before
we do that if I can interrupt you I
would like the record to show that the
lawyers for general Noriega through his
lead attorney in Florida mr. Nielsen at
were asked two weeks ago for any
evidence that might document what was
asserted in the document put forward
today by Jose Blondin secondly how I
join senator D'Amato in underscoring
what those a blind donors just said
about potential replacements the
intelligence on which our judgments have
been based is fundamentally
fundamentally not exclusively but
fundamentally intelligence which has
been fed over the years through general
Noriega himself so he has created really
the pages of files on potential
replacements and this is a point which
Jose Blondo made last time but I think
in view of the current debate and
administration position it's even more
important today to understand that than
it was before
now mr. Blandon would you please
re identify if you will who Nestor
Sanchez is what Nestor Sanchez who is he
identify employees mr. Sanchez worked
middle and doesn't immersed with the CIA
for various years in the Defense
Department you know as an assistant for
Latin America of the Defense Department
let me be the present time
he is part the young the town of our
committee yeah one of the committee's
indication and I understand when you see
is an adviser that the internment of way
recently he was assigned to the canal to
the Panama Canal Commission the man who
has been in continual relationship with
general River for a number of years his
knowledge of the Defense Forces is
limited to those areas and you know him
to be somebody who has continued to have
even at this moment input with respect
to defense perceptions on the Noriega
situation they see okay a lot was saying
that last year meeting with arquillian
oh boy close to who was named as
ambassador Panama to the United States
then and those discussion aquiline avoid
discussed with mr. Sanchez if you
develop or have been future of the
defense forces of Panama so this is gate
on the basis that if Noriega left la la
la Pira minidom and oh man pyramid would
now the was going to put Panama's ass
and the hands
the communist now with this simplistic
idea that's what he's been operating on
you don't need some they discussed this
sample because at that time you're
telling them why you're I was in New
York you know what I discussed this with
me and with lethal Ambassador Ritter of
the UN the Panamanian ambassador to the
UN discussed this problem that's the
Chairman um I believe that a meeting
took place this past Saturday a week ago
Saturday on March 25th we're a number of
officers in the Panamanian Defense
Department met at the Pentagon with the
Defense Department officials to discuss
the implementation of various
opportunities or methods by which
Noriega could be exited removed or
removed
news of that meeting apparently leaked
out and was made available in Panama and
I asked mr. Blandon if that is not
correct if he did not hear that there
were meetings that taking place with our
Defense Department with the PDF members
of PDF officers and I understand that
mr. Sanchez was seen in the Pentagon
Lobby at the time of this meeting are
you aware of that
saying yes I discussed this with the
mayor and he said that when they were in
the Defense Department he said hello to
mr. Sanchez this was Saturday the day
that you mentioned Domingo and Sunday
you know you know intaglio a Panama and
the you know this came out on Sunday in
the Panamanian papers that they had met
with defense officials in the
United States who provided the lead I
don't know but this is what happened is
there any additional information you can
tell us about the relationship between
Nestor Sanchez and general Noriega I
think that you haven't told us just that
they have a good friendship I think with
this he then appeared on videos
discussed this thesis of the high
command domain in addition and a
collapse of the leadership defense
forces yeah and he has put this out his
thoughts were true now unless son of
Germano wants to pursue that I want to
move back into the Medellin Cartel mr.
chairman it's an office and they just
realized something and I'm not going to
bring you public at this point but I
think unless the Defense Department
begins to look into the relationship
with Nestor Sanchez and that which he
did have with Noriega and the fact that
that when this kind of meeting takes
place at this critical juncture and it's
a meeting that I wasn't aware of mr.
chairman but somehow it finds its way
that information finds its way in Panama
that that's rather distressing and the
fact of the matter is that maybe they
should look a little closer into what
the relationship with Nestor Sanchez and
Noriega has been and continues to be and
what maybe Noriega has what information
that might be rather embarrassing the
Nestor Sanchez the Noriega has and what
influence he still may exercise and I
think it's a rather serious matter and
disturbs this senator to think that
we're still operating on the premise and
the basis of information that flows
through this individual and the fact
that he just so coincidentally turns up
at the time that this meeting has been
held and the fact that this information
gets back that these officers have met
with the Defense Department people to
Noriega and
I for one think that it's a rather
disturbing situation and I think there's
a rather myopic point of view that still
persist and exist and for the life of me
I can't understand how this how this
philosophy of just wait for things to
take place and things may get better
when indeed we have information mr.
chairman that later I'd like to share
with you that that may lead to a
situation where upwards of a hundred
plus million dollars may be transferred
and in the hours and weeks and days
ahead and cash money that to Noriega and
I wonder how that situation will play
out if he's given that infusion of
dollars and how much longer and what the
people of Panama what will do and I'd
like this one other question because
after was a plan don't is an operative
and intelligence operative with many
many years experience understanding the
psychology of the Panamanian people
probably better than anyone we have
access to mr. Blandon in your opinion if
the situation persist in Noriega is able
to continue in power for the next three
four four weeks
how will the Panamanian people will
there begin to take place a shift in the
sentiment of the Panamanian people
against the United States as a result of
the fact that they have been led to
believe that he would be out a long time
ago and they have endured so much in a
way of sacrifice personal political
economic etc do you think that's a
danger you will recall senator you know
consumer Simoni know your debt when we
spoke in New York you let me say King in
many months who I told you that in March
the Noriega government would enter into
a general crisis common victim in theta
as indeed is the case you'll oppose I
would try can assure you that a man a
single polio Jaeger remains in power in
la prossima Quattro semana for the next
four weeks
Noriega body ruin
then I Kaname go destroy the Panamanian
economic system ela destruction del
sistema economic destruction of the
panelist Tim will break you Logan its
wake a up on the road McLaughlin media
can also promote a sermon by exit of the
powerful middle class can be forged in
the country how dummy my fila there are
long lines in my Hanuma right now you
obtain the final authorities is to come
to the United States economy upon a
menial very near economy attack once a
Vida is conceived her but as their also
then with drop of human here Africa so
as to make use of a geographic location
they think I think Oh por ciento England
75% of the Union desert me he'll income
of the Panamanian government services if
Noriega is able to destroy the financial
system la moneda and establishes a
national currency economic open I mean
even in economic system will be changed
he must have illegally and later coma
until even if I will explain how Cuban
intelligence is no money London a
problem has been manipulating this
problem is the position so as to come to
such a juncture
ok what about him a feminine so that the
next four weeks Somme week Clara very
clearly decisive Panama the United
States decides to wait believe you know
it dangerous states it's a strategic
security yell polio kokorin terminals
and the racism all tell open your the
danger in public opinion being turned
against the United States is very great
splendid I want to try to proceed
through a number of other key areas we
have a great deal to cover a lot of
witnesses and unfortunately not as much
time as we would like in previous
testimony you told us that general
Noriega had a relationship with other
military intelligence officials
throughout the region
did he have a relationship with the
Honduran military intelligence signal
yes of course can you describe for us
who Colonel Torres Ras is
Colonel Torres areas around towards
areas general intelligence beyond
Iranian wears a under an intelligence -
in officer he was head of the g2 which
is the military intelligence of hunters
and he was changed you know in the end
of 81 the end of beginning of 82 and
what was his relationship with general
Noriega who initially Sharia'a Noriega
in a pico de Armas with bigger was
initiated to arms trafficking and drug
trafficking by Noriega in Doha cos
Univision on two occasions he visited
Havana he said all new Yahoo own Castro
and he met there with Castro and with
members of the FMLN ordinary limb bill
the Adam to coordinate the shipment of
arms through Honduras at what period of
time did general Noriega and Taurus
arias enter into a business relationship
and give me more mental at the same time
gotta fill them in that they met a young
cartel west for me you showed that the
Medellin Cartel was at the beginning of
the 1980s communal reporte as a day low
response on the part of the drug barons
in Colombia represented by the m-19
Jelena see that the new one is to have a
coordinated strategy and Iommi intense
enables you to increase their business
it is a video loop from that time
diminishing
when an ad in cartel was formed with a
clear strategy with resources not only
financial resources but also human
resources I love India because there's a
tendency to think are Tallulah as a very
crude murders the trafficker pill but
behind this cartel people technique
there's a whole technical team economist
economists viren thieriot financiers a
mentoring the human investment experts
who manage these tremendous quantities
of money American organized a few now
when let me just interrupt you there
when Ramona and rodriguez testified he
sat there and he said two US senators
you don't understand these people
control whole industries industries is
that accurate
I mean of course not only industries
member of the cartel not the median
cartel but if Cali Cali Kayla Hilbert or
another thing Quinta you control 51% of
that bank you know let me come back for
a second because I want to try to be
very precise here what to the best of
your recollection and if you don't
remember tell us you don't remember that
approximately what year did this
relationship with Colonel arias begin
with general Noriega below is hidden in
1980 now the nature of the business you
have described as being narcotics and
arms is that the totality of it for
myself only will kill the animal it
began with arms business first arms
trafficking when did it move into
narcotics no elephant died you know in
1981 where there are other Honduran
military officers or officials involved
already Tyson after Taurus arias you
mean yes well even at the same time was
torre area it was taurus arias alone in
his effort was he where that was he
joined by others bowling no he worked
with Colonel Burton la una de la una who
controls one of the most powerful units
of Honduras you know people that are in
las nueve was the type of relationship
that you see now in Haiti
II won't equal mean local Noriega just
as that which also began with Noriega
and is very important or the pattern
rather the pattern in a funeral cartel
Quran who chooses the highest level
official working or officer working in
the agency so Noriega was g2
Taurus arias joris arias was g2 boding
come to la una de los button controls
one of the most powerful units of
Honduras NIT in Haiti and Coronel
involucre lo the room is the most
powerful officer yell cartel get in ma
holding firm assumed intelligence he and
the cartel which has better intelligence
information about the officers than the
US intelligence agencies memorable
Dominion has a better system of
recruitment either there is the momento
and from that moment it's fun they want
to fill him in the Union we know he's
into a decision from that moment in 1881
that the nevian cars are expanded via
party daniel amelong a giant ocean tight
respond only during a 1983 when it's
true expansion again before you go to
the expansion what was Colonel buttons
unit which unit but the battalion I
don't remember the name that's based in
Tegucigalpa and is he still an active
duty officer in Honduras no you know
that do they are not active they were
retired when general Alvarez came to
power in 1982 was there any specific
reason stated for their retirement at
the time porque la intially because the
hunter and intelligence agency and US
intelligence agencies a persevere don't
perceive module then our own genetic
they come to this information about
meetings with Castro with and you'll
recall that I informed in the last one
Gary Busey Malayan Portman soonduk that
when we receive the information that
what Matthew
England ordinary information into
hunters about Torres arias and I travel
to Cuba Noriega pass this information on
to US intelligence agencies did they
ship weapons to the rebels in El
Salvador
c'mon oh of course say of course
but you know that or do you say of
course because everybody did it no no no
big Maria Corden because Noriega
coordinated meetings in Panama una
dirección de frente para mundo Marty
with the director of the parable know
Marty front and the room in Italy to
establish two outs for armed supply to
El Salvador
una pelea holding and hopefully Fonseca
one through and beneath and through the
Gulf of Fonseca and another in the north
of Honduras which was called the Ho Chi
Minh Trail is the point equal doodle
hari any bullying this was discussed by
Doris arias in meetings in Panama you
attend any of those meetings you know
unity I attended both to meetings of
both meetings
can you describe to us who is
matta-ballesteros matta-ballesteros is a
drug trafficker you know who is
originally Colombian in winter in Lula
who is currently in Honduras did
matta-ballesteros have a relationship
with Noriega Nokia's about not that I
know of what was his role in Honduran
drug trafficking can you bring the mic
down a little bit good thank you
matta-ballesteros a human movement
arrest eros is a multi-billionaire
different edema Souness indigent is
different estimates indicate that his
fortune is greater than 1 billion
dollars the body Mahina an evil
influence you could imagine the any
degree of influence that he has in
honduras is he the same
matta-ballesteros who was wanted by for
the prosecution in the murder of the DEA
drug agent Camarena ending yes it's the
same one
so this wanted accused murderer alleged
murderer who is one of the richest men
in Honduras is yes currently under
indictment for murder of an America of a
DEA agent is currently sitting in
Honduras at the moment with impunity is
that correct correct oh yes it is
correct and do you know how long he has
been there no no I don't know
who in the Honduran military picked up
the drug business after Torres arias if
you know
who Teresa cuando sorry oh you mean when
Toria said yes left the Armed Forces yes
Paloma Senora que the problem senator
control over assume Casey dollar listen
to annual change operation being carried
out in 83 and 84 in Honduras the support
a military military support no one
against Nicaragua along condiciones
nominated natural conditions but at the
vehicle for illicit activities now are
you talking about the supply effort to
the Contras in 83 84 is that thunder
exactly well apart apart from the
natural opportunities that it afforded
do you personally have knowledge of
Honduran involvement subsequent Torres
arias in drug trafficking the put a
little in Panama via evidentialism in
Panama there were indications of family
with ancient kami permiten
indications that envelope them into
evidence that would allow me to indicate
direct involvement let me ask you this
question was there an involvement to
your knowledge and drug trafficking by
the Honduran Navy no enormous interfere
you refer to the aim to the Navy or the
army or the Navy an innate and Navy no
nothing was consumed in does no I do not
have knowledge of that do you know who
had to reply Cano is see yes did you
describe to us who he is
even call an editor then a person
Armando Lenya he's a colonel and I'm
versus who was discharged 1986 you know
whether or not he was involved with drug
smuggling while he oversaw the Contras
supply efforts in Honduras not only for
my soon the kid I do not have
information that he was get off the drug
trafficking I do know that he was the
link between in the continent between
the Contras and hunter and army
do you know a Honduran officer named
captain Luke a have I pronounced that
correctly
according to Luke al open attacks right
and okay I mean where's the operative
who is involved in the same work well
what do you mean involved in the same
work it's rather complicated to me need
to work with African out in supplying
the Contras and he worked at the account
at the air strips that were used for
resupply is that correct correct yes it
is correct
now at some time did Cesar Rodriguez
tell you that drugs were going through
those strips said Olivia Sarah Rodriguez
these are real police our Lupita's
Rodriguez used to the airstrip in Costa
Rica
it is ailment it basically but you told
us some time previously that says our
agreed to Rodriguez told you that those
airstrip slanderous were being used also
for the transshipment is that correct
correct dole okay each okay Costa Rica
he also made stops in our mainly he
operated from Costa Rica do you know
whether or not trafficking through
Honduras has continued up until the
present time nothing with one machine I
do not have information in this regard
and can you tell us the circumstances of
the visit of Torres arias and and Bodine
to Cuba la villita the area a building
in Quattroporte Rosario's and Putin's
travel to Cuba which was on two
occasions Dylan it is the other record
by virtually to resupply a momento my
Pacifico more specific are and we mean
to eleven million to the FMLN movement
he para table funeral assume whom and to
establish a relationship with Castro's
personnel mahogany unit alone so that
they would be trusted with the visit of
the guerrillas in El Salvador what was
general Noriega role in that he is a
little nippy no Panama they went to
Panama ETO recommended Havana Panama and
theoretically they were in Panama eundel
a Panamanian phenomenon and an armed
forces plane of the Panamanian armed
forces taped them to Havana
and that's the totality of his role in
that we know a lot of them they're not
able to see in terms of arranging the
visits yes but but general Noriega had a
business relationship with them with
respect to the results of that visit is
that correct a little of course simply a
travel on midday through Minnie through
the elevator after the recent arms
resupply network that Noriega had in
like equals the young Aramis in which to
change the parents from the in different
countries business at all three days
with no Cesar Rodriguez and the red
naughty Anita Dennis
they continued the armed supply now mr.
Blandon you told me also on a number of
occasions in my office as we discuss
this that the clandestine network of air
strips which were used for the Contras
supply that is to say both in Costa Rica
as well as in Honduras were also used
extensively by drug traffickers is that
accurate same air strips be done with a
bundle vote please repeat the question
you said to me on a couple of occasions
in my office as we discuss this that the
air strips the clandestine network
secret network of air strips which were
used for Cointreau supply we're also
used extensively for drug trafficking
are you a former film hero
there's some inflammation you know that
I would like to set forth senator but
let's it is here because of the Illinois
vanadium McCune insistence of more
convincing evidence illegally links the
array read the error a network could
have made not a little with respect to
out this Horizonte Vicki entertainer
when you say you're gonna lose some
people here when you say the Harari
you're talking about Mike kirari
is that correct see maravillosa Mirren
yes I'm referring to the Israeli citizen
Guinea negocio Noriega fo has business
with people moving companies for arms
contraband when after an atom on to
supply arms a syndrome Erika Yohn
eternal America and to the
counter-revolution the Nicaraguan
counter-revolution you can amass a
soumimaria nosara tacos and moreover
those planes were used for other little
EE when you say other things what do you
mean they're all that drugs and when you
say the Ferrari Network
what is the Harare Network now they
played da da da da orion network is the
network established with israeli citizen
external Panamanian and US citizens for
armed supply purposes
when was this formed in the middle of a
theologian titled in the dress in 1982
and 83 with into Hindi say it functioned
until 1986 where did it function from
data Panama from Panama what countries
wasn't involved with considerable Italy
I would like to ask mr. chairman a tad
emma is helical pedal this topic has
been discussed another bookie you know
could this be discussed enclosed why
because there's a witness in the United
a dramatist who is still pending as some
serious measures yeah yeah we I spoke
with him yesterday the idea came to head
I would prefer ceremony hello that this
be another premier dealt with in a
closed session first
mr. bun don't let me I'm gonna we will
agree to do that we will do that in a
closed session and I understand why and
I and I think it is important but I want
to do it immediately I can close us not
this moment this instant but within the
next few days is that agreeable see yes
before we move off this subject I want
to ascertain for the public record
without any question that this involves
[Music]
that there is a direct linkage that
you're aware of of the private network
that the sorority network and these air
strips in which guns would go in one
shipment and drugs would come out in
another is that accurate correct oh yes
and on some occasions drugs just went in
and out on their own that's also
accurate is it not correct yes we will
pursue the names and the particular
individual that I'm aware of and staff
is aware of and we've already been in
touch with them as a matter of fact so
we will pursue that in closed session
and move into another area
when general Noriega took over the
government from president of IA actually
formalized his takeover in a public way
at that time at the beginning of the
month the japanese government decided to
approve the new government installed by
Noriega and at that point we began our
economic sanctions has there been a
relationship between general Noriega and
japan that we should be aware of
moratorium in t well historically they
republican in excellent relations with
the government of japan develop oka from
the time they're in an elderly who of
general Torrijos
yeah in a nunnery ago obviamente Noriega
obviously inherited those good relations
no interest is they are polling panama
students interests in panama are very
significant you know one are sitting in
that presence and they will be so in the
future what i saw this at home because
owner of japan isn't a net exporter of
commodities important so we were Japan
you know open and relations are very
important that is a way for Japan and we
Panamanians are interested in
cultivating that relationship know I'd
been asked by check one minute here
I think we'll take a 10-minute recess at
this time reconvene at 20 minutes of we
stand in recess for 10 minutes